have you ever been to japan yourself uh
once yeah we
uh
oh god what year was it it was before it
was like 2019 i think right um right
before the pandemic yeah we went because
i got offered to go to a thing with
because godzilla was coming out and
detective pikachu oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
second godzilla movie so we got to go
with like warner brothers flew us out to
do a thing right and then because my
girlfriend lived there and she's fluent
and everything was like can we like
extend our trip so we went for 10 days
oh nice nice four on our own and then
the rest was like doing stuff with those
awesome yeah did it feel like it was
enough days were you like oh no i need
more
i think for that trip it was because we
ended with all the like pressed junk
yeah
okay it felt like we we like revisited
the same place we went to like harajuku
the first time when we were there and
then we got to see like the temples and
stuff and then when we went back it was
like here you go again but it's like
scheduled out so it was a little
different but yeah we got to go to the
the touhou place and we got to see like
all the original like props for all the
earlier movies
right right like the original like
costume and everything was there yeah
yeah yeah yeah that stuff was really
cool got to see ryan reynolds again
oh yeah yeah yeah
he waved at me you're in free guy yeah
he will have touched you
well that was the thing i met him for
the deadpool thing and then the
detective pikachu thing he was on a boat
he was like hey that guy and he like
waved down at me
i was like holy [ __ ]
he remembers you remembered me
and then we like took a picture all
together and i was like standing next to
him being like
good to see him
i will remember this smell so there was
a lot of things in that trip that like
made it a much bigger deal yeah yeah
yeah well how did like the free guy and
like the deadpool collab come about and
what was it like you know
being in projects like that fluke right
when the deadpool deadpool was coming
out the second one and then i loved the
first one already and i was such a
massive fan of ryan anyway yeah and then
i was talking about him so much in my
videos and just kind of like kind of
annoyingly i would say i feel like if
someone did that
i'd be like [ __ ] weirdo but i i've
been talking about him so much that he
liked one of my tweets one day
people were just badgering him about me
yeah yeah i was i was coming back from a
trip one time and then saw on my phone
that he had followed me and i was like
oh [ __ ]
i was like it was like dad found my
account oh no
delete everything yeah but then
i think that happened and then i had
played the deadpool game
just because for search engine the movie
was coming out yeah yeah yeah yeah
people are watching and then i think
warner brothers whoever over at the time
got wind of that and then got in contact
with me and we're like well now we have
to put you in a room together because
you guys have interacted you've played
the game and yeah then cause of that it
like snowballed from there to like all
the other celebrities right
wow it was just random chance it was a
pure miracle
that's so cool
basically just meme up your favorite
celebrity right and then just yeah yeah
he has to be the biggest fan boy
that's like the worst story ever
keep
[Laughter]
that was that was i played the game and
i was like is that because it's not like
the grainiest [ __ ] i'm like is that
yeah and you just see like my chin
and then once my full face comes in
everyone has the same reaction yeah yeah
yeah what was that all about i mean like
again in the first chapter i was like
yeah i could do a voice in this game put
me in the game and then they messaged me
afterwards being like do you want to be
in the game
i was like it's that easy yeah i just
[ __ ] annoy people
but i i've been in a couple of things
like bendy and the ink machine and
popper combo oh okay yeah so i think
they were just like yeah be in it but i
i didn't think i'd be a person in it
they were like
it was just tapes of voices the first
time and i was like i can do that oh you
thought it was just gonna be a voice of
you yeah yeah right and then they sent
me the thing and it was like dress up in
like a yellow shirt and like have a
lanyard which they didn't give me a
template for and i had to make right um
and then i was like okay i'll act and i
was like [ __ ] now i have to like learn
the lines like be in a camera and like
right it took me like seven times just
to get like a sentence i would just feel
like big brain though instead of having
to play the game yourself just be in
every other life yeah yeah
it works out great then i played and i'm
like i'm in puppy playtime
how is it like having to like memorize
the script versus just you know doing a
let's play or just being a youtuber i
guess because i feel like there must be
so much more pressure because yeah yeah
do you have like an acting background
yeah well you're just waiting not at all
yeah just winging it i just well i i'm a
huge fan of just watching movies and i
love acting in general and i always
thought i would do it eventually yeah
and i have like mini characters on my
own channel where i like play them every
now and then yeah want to do something
with those in the future and i that was
like a sandbox for me to just play
around in it though and be like if i can
do it i'll figure it out
but these things was like just here's a
roll if you want to do it right right
right for them here and there and
i don't know it's weird it's a fun
challenge though i think yeah oh
definitely definitely yeah because i
guess uh i guess
i guess you just kind of like in three
guys it was kind of like a cameo so you
kind of just got like to play yourself i
guess right yeah it was really bizarre
because when i when they sent me the
thing being like if you want to be in
the free guy and i was like it's a movie
with ryan reynolds why wouldn't i be i
was like i'll do literally anything
my boy ryan my boy yeah we're friends by
the way
we're basically free you open up your
ryan reynolds shrine and you're just
like you flex berserk on me i'll flex
right now
it's definitely a bigger flank yeah he
texts me a video for my birthday this
year
saying like happy birthday and like damn
that's like a 700 cameo right there yeah
just got your name wrong
good to see you john
[Laughter]
yeah for free guy it was i got like a
script of like there's like a bunny
rabbit character in it when they go into
the world right and it was like those
lines and i was like oh [ __ ] that's like
a character and i thought it was like oh
just walk in the background yeah yeah
yeah yeah sean levy the director i had a
call with and i was like here learning
these lines and i was like okay treat
this as an audition okay and i was like
[ __ ] and breaks i'm even getting nervous
now thinking about it right it was so
scary and then i got on the phone with
him he's the most infectiously happy guy
of all time he was like yeah we have
this movie and we're gonna do it we'd
love to have you in it and it's so cool
like you'd play yourself and i was like
oh this is i don't have to do anything
did i get the pot
should i do a british accent
so did i get the audition how do i how
do i how do i stack up against the other
jacksepticeye auditions
honestly i would lose that order
i have no idea how to be myself
but he like he'd like text me the lines
like a script right for an sms and i was
like we're just shooting from the hip
wow and i got to sit in my room like
with my camera and do it
like they were like have it to us by
like monday or whatever but i was
allowed to do it on my own with no
direction and right they came back and
they were like that was incredible we
want you to in it more here's more lines
so
if you watch the movie it was like the
very starting part was the only part i
had initially right i kept showing up
again and again because they were like
you were so good let's put you in again
i was like great and then they were like
yeah ninja was like in it and he sent us
like a c920 logitech webcam
i was like ninja come on
so then his part in the movie has like a
like a motion rig and like a really big
camera yeah now mine looks like [ __ ]
super fun really really cool experience
to be proud of yeah
people like as of like two days ago my
chiropractor messaged me being like i
saw free guy it was incredible i didn't
know you were in it
yeah that that is an awesome flex